last time on true fear I talked about
the crazy lady that I saw in a hotel if
that sounds interesting to you or you
want to check out any of the first three
episode I'm going to leave a link and
there will be another one at the end of
this video as well so as most of you
guys know I'm a die-hard Cubs fan so
back in October I booked myself a flight
back home to Chicago so that I could be
there when that moment happened when the
Cubs won the World Series and that was
probably the best two weeks of my life
and it was probably the most exciting
world series of all time but one thing
that kind of got overshadowed in the
excitement was that I almost didn't make
my flight out because of what happened
on the way to the airport so usually
when I go to the airport I take the
metro to this Coach bus that drops me
off at LA s it takes a few hours to get
there and I have to leave pretty early
to make all the transfers so I get to
the subway station and there's already a
train sitting on the tracks loading up
the first two cars looked kind of full
so I kept walking down and the third car
was kind of pull as well but I was
afraid the doors were going to close so
I just looked in there and sat down
normally I would just go onto the
closest car but for some reason I chose
this car so I get into the car and I've
got my headphones and I'm not really
paying much attention to the world
around me but I'm sitting there for
about 15 minutes and I really start to
get concerned because the trains are
supposed to run like every 10 minutes or
something
they make an announcement on the
intercom that there is a problem with
the train at the top ahead of us in
Universal City that was causing a delay
and as soon as I was cleared they would
be set to depart I was thinking about
getting out and taking an uber but I
wasn't ready to throw the money that I
had saved by taking the Metro just yet
so I just decided to stick it out a
little while longer
that's when I noticed some commotion
going on in the railcar and took out my
headphone people were talking about some
guy holding a shotgun I turned around
looked out the window to see this Metro
security guard standing right there with
a huge gun so people were freaking out
and most of them remain seated it was a
pretty tense environment and I was
starting to get the sense that this
whole thing about the Universal City
train was a lie there was this one
gentleman in a brown shirt who actually
got out and was talking to one of the
security guards I couldn't hear the
conversation but I assumed he was
getting information from them based on
what happened that he got back in and
sat down a few feet from where I was
after that there was some back-and-forth
between this brown shirt guy and this
other guy who was sitting way at the end
of my car who was wearing a grey shirt
at the time basically the brown shirt
guy was telling the grey shirt guy to
hop up off the train because he
supposedly fits the description the grey
shirt guy was claiming his innocence but
the brown shirt guy suggested he should
leave for his own good
roll it I will afraid row and then at
the same time that this was going on I'm
just about ready to hop off and call an
uber when there's another announcement
on the intercom he tells us that they're
still having issues with the Train at
Universal and that he was going to close
the doors to our train so that when the
issue is cleared up we can leave right
away
clearly a lie I can understand not
wanting to raise panic but when you just
clearly lying like that it's just going
to raise more panic and confusion
now we're all trapped on this train with
the killer potentially inside with us
people are freaking out calamity is
rising back to the gray shirt guy he
won't budge so the brown shirt guy
starts telling him that he ought to take
the gray shirt offer something's but he
doesn't look suspicious he actually did
take the shirt off at some point and
underneath Oh another guy yells out he
went upstairs which I guess is a
suggestion that the one they're looking
for got off the train and went back up
to the service I don't know where he got
that idea maybe he just wanted to train
to depart already there were a couple
other snippets that I didn't record but
I wrote down I heard someone was arguing
with the guy he had a gray tank top
another rider stated he had a 2-inch
pipe and a wad of cash weird guy then of
course there was the guy who seemed to
think that every black male in the train
was going to be shot then at some point
the gunmen start marching up the
platform which of course stirred a big
commotion in the train he was joined by
another guy with a handgun
and the third guy who didn't seem to
have a weapon so I guess they were
checking each car one by one or
something so eventually they busted into
the rail car I was in roll it
so you see they actually get off the car
and then something I'm not sure what
tipped the guy off and the security
guards or officers or whatever they are
get back on and start questioning mr.
gray shirt they asked him if he had a
grey shirt I'm not sure what he said and
he pretty much gives himself up so they
escort him off the train I'm not sure
what happens to the gray shirt that he
had on originally to be honest the other
thing that confused me was when they
came on the train they said it was a
gray shirt white shorts this guy had
black shorts so did they even get the
right guy eventually I heard people
talking and saying that this guy stabbed
someone before getting on the train when
they started emptying out his pockets
they did plot a knife among many other
things maybe they did get the right guy
maybe not maybe he's still at large
because one of the other things that I
noticed was that they continued to
search the rest of the train after
catching the guy in my rail car now
right here we see what looks like an
LAPD officer bringing him some other guy
who comes up looks at the suspect and
nod I'm going to assume that this is a
witness of the crime who they're
bringing in to identify the criminal if
that was the case then it seems like
they did get the right guy because after
that the guards convened and seemed to
be like making a plan to escort the
suspect out of this train station and as
soon as that happens the train gets
moving
before that though they made one last
announcement on the intercom and said
that the train ahead of us in Universal
City was successfully taken off the
track and we could get underway and
that's the part that I hated most about
the way that this was handled there are
windows on the train everyone saw what
just went on we aren't stupid there's no
reason to lie and patronize your
customers dude we got to Universal City
and there are a couple people who got on
the train at that point and I tried
asking if anything had gone down at that
stop but unfortunately they didn't speak
English so I wasn't able to get any more
information I still have no idea how
that guy in the brown shirt knew that
the grey shirt guy was the one that they
were looking for based on such a generic
description he may have very well saved
us though so props to that guy the rest
of my trip to Chicago is safe exactly
one year after being eliminated on the
day that Back to the Future 2
prophesized that we would become
champions I was on the way home to the
finale of the NLCS
the next day Kyle Hendricks outdueled
clayton kershaw for the pennant and then
11
well technically 12 days later the
drought came to an end and the ghosts of
harry carey could finally rest in peace
speaking of the ghosts of harry carey
join me next time on true.you as i jump
back to five years ago when the ghost of
harry caray appeared in our group
photograph not clickbait i actually have
proof so if you want to hear about that
or if you're interested in any of the
other horror shows here on this channel
remember to like this video and
subscribe for new Horrors every other
week ring the desk bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]